turning to the coronavirus we could be
on the verge of a major landmark in that
fight the new york times reports the
pfizer vaccine could get full fda
approval today taking it beyond its
current emergency youth authorization
and it comes as the u.s is consistently
topping 100 thousand new covet cases
every day that's for the first time
since january we're joined now by dr
ashish jah dean of brown university
school of public health dr john good
morning uh good day to have you on here
because it could be a big day in this
fight against the coronavirus what
effect do you believe full authorization
could have on our vaccine rate in this
country
yeah good morning and thanks for having
me here i i think this is really good
news if it comes through and i actually
think it's going to end up making a
pretty big difference i mean for some
people
the emergency use has been a barrier to
getting vaccinated and for a lot of
companies and businesses and schools
they have been waiting for this full
approval before mandating vaccine so i
think it's going to set off a whole new
wave of vaccinations which i think will
be very helpful given where we are as a
country do you think that increase in
the vaccination rate will happen
naturally as people see this full
authorization or does something more
need to be done from a public health
point of view to bring people on board i
think it will help some portion of
people maybe five or ten percent of the
population i think is holding out for
this and i think
that will help that group but i also
think a lot of big businesses are
waiting and with this full approval
they'll feel a lot more comfortable
asking their employees to get vaccinated
yeah dr xia we're looking at booster
shots now in the fall we've had trouble
getting a lot of people to take that
first or second shot
what do you think we need to do to get
people to take booster shots
yeah so look booster shots are going to
be necessary for some people i don't
think every american is going to need it
but certainly high-risk people
immunocompromise older people people
with chronic diseases i think those
folks are going to be
up for it i think they're going to get
the boosters because they know it's
going to offer that extra level of
protection i don't think this should
dissuade anybody from getting vaccinated
given where we are right now as a
country with more than a hundred
thousand infections uh this is not a
good time to be unvaccinated so i hope
people get started dr shah are you among
those who think the call for a booster
shot is premature at this point is that
what you're saying that for most people
i mean
i don't look the data is emerging on
this and so we've got to continue to
follow what the data is and the data
from israel for instance is really
compelling that after about six months
after your second shot the immunity
starts waning a little bit and therefore
i think the administration made the
right call certainly for high-risk
people i want to see a little more data
on average people with normal kind of
risk profile i'm not convinced yet that
they need a they need a booster they
might we want to see where the data goes
yeah because people are saying how do we
know getting a third shot is safe a lot
of people are worried and wondering
about that but
i'm i'm paying attention to you listen
the fda has issued a warning because
some people are now taking a livestock
dewormer it's a veterinarian medici
medicine i love the fda issuing a
warning this morning that says this
you're not a horse you're not a cow stop
it could you weigh in on this just the
fact that people even think that this is
a viable option
yeah there's a lot of misinformation out
there about this medicine called
ivermectin which is uh used largely in
livestock
suggesting that somehow it's this very
effective medicine it look we the
clinical trials have been run we have
not seen any evidence that ivermectin is
helpful for people with covid
if we if that if evidence emerges the
fda and all of us will call for people
to use it but right now people going to
livestock shows and
and veterinarians and getting this
medicine is very very dangerous all
right dr jaw and to all the cows and
horses out there of course we do wish
them a speedy recovery yes you're not a
horse or a cat
dr john thank you very much